good evening and welcome to this meeting
of the audit committee
i will read out the emergency evacuation
announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building via the entrance doors to the
hall
continue straight on and exit the
building via the double doors on the
right up to the car park
which is the assembly point
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff
please note this meeting will be audio
recorded
and switch off mobiles to turn them to
silent
members there are four microphones on
the tables
for use during the meeting when i invite
you to speak please wait until there is
a microphone in front of you before
speaking as microphones are needed for
the hearing loop and for the audio
recording
please where possible assist in passing
microphones to each other
and use the hand gel and antibacterial
wipes on the tables if you do touch the
microphones
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands for and
against recommendations
and will then ask for any abstinent
abstentions
excuse me
right gender item one apologies for
absence
we have
received none in the
office
agenda item two substitute members
there are none
agenda item three non-members attending
councillor high
is
in the building good evening
agenda item 4
minutes of the meeting held on the 27th
of july 2021
are the minutes agreed members
agenda item five
to receive declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest members
nope
agenda item six
audit progress report
this will be presented by mr jim caveney
but can you please note the title of
this
is
of this um report states audit progress
report 2020 21
this should read audit progress report
2122
so the principal auditor
internal audit jim cavani will present
the report
thank you chairman
good evening members
um this is our first
progress report covering this year's
work
from may our resource available has
increased by the return from maternity
leave of our auditor on a part-time
basis
the first part of enclosure one on page
6.3 gives an outline of the work that
was completed to the end of august which
is the point that this report was
compiled
work to identify and rectify fraud and
error is substantially carried out by
the revenues and benefits team this is
an additional to
addition to additional workloads
undertaken to deal with the issues
arriving from the kovya pandemic
data on page 6.4
provides details of amounts recovered by
the team for the year to the 20th of
august
a detailed summary of completed audit
work is shown in appendix 1 on page 6.5
with associated reports starting in
appendix 2 on page 6.7
with a light touch report in appendix 3
on page 6.16
appendix 4 starting on page 6.17
provides the current position on audit
recommendations that were in place at
the last session of this committee and
details those raised since then
i'm happy to take any questions
are there any questions
counsellor dry
thank you chairman um i note that um uh
bazidan council um have the role as
chief audit executive i'm just wondering
if they charge us for that and if there
is what is the charge matter of interest
and do rochefort district council
act
as a chief audit executive for any other
council
also it was noted in the presentation
at 1.6
the the full-time equivalent staff is
sorry at 4.1 that the full-time
equivalent staff is now 1.6
um as a matter of opinion is that
adequate
uh is that sufficient adequate staffing
um thank you councillor for your
question um with regards to the chief
audit audit executive role um
provided by basildon council um yeah
that arrangement's been in place for a
couple of um probably three years now
isn't it um
and basically that was because we didn't
have a kind of suitable candidate
available to us at rockford and it was
felt that was the best value for money
solution for the council and provided
the best expertise um to us that that
arrangement is chargeable and
it's charged on a sort of
time basis so yeah we've got budget set
aside for that and we we generally sort
of underspend against
against that budget each year but um
yeah that it's charged out on the time
actually spent okay any idea of how much
that is
um it's around kind of um 13 to 15 000
pounds per annum
um but it does vary as i say on natural
time time spent and with regards to the
rest of the um
audit resource
um mike obviously as the chief audience
executive has to take a view on the
resource needed to deliver the audit
plan each year and he makes that
assessment as part of the internal audit
plan um
it is felt there's sufficient resource
at the moment to carry out the audit
plan and obviously we have managed
before um becky came back from tennessee
leave with just um mike and jim
um
so yeah with the 1.6
fte that that's provides sufficient
resource to do what we need to do
thank you
thank you
any further questions
can you wait for the um oh sorry all
right
regarding handling of customer
complaints
have i gone too far forward what page
are you on 6.9
it says 12 out of 20 cases did not meet
this expected time scale so we're
looking at the the way the
other part departments respond to
complaints
and i wondered what work's been done to
improve that
german thank you um
the customer services team have taken
this on uh with a really effect from
this april
and are working to
reconsider
a realistic time frame sometimes you're
an organization we pick historically
it's been five days for years
um
some in some cases i've done within the
time sometimes take longer and i think
what we're really looking to do is make
a realistic assessment based on the type
of complaint we get
rather than pick a target which we can't
meet would be something look for
something much more realistic
um
one of the issues
apparently seems to be um into
departments getting back to each other
sort of responding
i just wondered um it says somewhere in
there that you use a spreadsheet are you
not looking to update
the technology so that the complaints
are locked and anyone looking at can see
those complaints and dip in and out of
the
programs uh yes i can so the spreadsheet
is a historic thing and uh is looking to
be processed i
believe the
the new
was recently approved for one of the
connect projects to bring in some
digital stuff which will enable direct
monitoring and production of data from
the system and as councillors will we be
feeding into that so when we're
receiving complaints
and we feed those in or deal with those
complaints
and will these then be recorded into the
system so that you know they can be
addressed that way as well so you've got
records i'm just concerned that if as a
if i was a customer that when i ring up
that the history of my complaint is
known the persons that are dealing with
it when i run it's all recorded and i
think that's part of delivering a really
good customer service is having
information that whoever picks up
a phone to me or deals with complaint
has access to all that information if
you've got different staff on different
days etc
the customer service team have access to
the spreadsheet now so they should be
able to provide a sort of a as much as
possible
status but um
the new system should provide a better
process but i don't i don't know how
that will be fed through to
into that yeah members thank you
thank you councillor mrs shaw
thank you jeff this is for jim you're
saying that um you're gonna have a new
um timeline for time limit for answering
uh
complaints
do you know what that time line is if we
can't meet five do you know what it is
and the second one and this will follow
on if
a counselor or a member of the public
because we're still all members of the
public put in a complaint
via email
are we actually going to get an
acknowledgement to say it's been
received because it's not happening at
the moment um so
we just don't know if that complaint has
actually been received
and it's gone to the right department
thank you
and with your permission chair i'm just
going to answer um part of jim um
the customer service charter is a piece
of work that's being revisited at the
moment by the um strategic director and
the assistant director for
transformation and
customer so i believe that's kind of
being finalized in terms of the exact um
time frames um that will be associated
with that so i believe that's something
that will be shared with all members um
relatively soon but i don't have the
exact time frame for that i'm afraid um
but yeah we can take that away and um
yeah get get get some a bit more detail
for you on that um with regards to
member inquiries i believe they are
treated um slightly separately at the
moment from um general kind of customer
inquiries um but again i think the sort
of expectations about timelines for that
will be set out as part of that new
customer charter and yeah which should
mirror the um
the same level of service obviously
that's um given to um customers
generally
second point was naomi um
if i send an email in
uh regarding a complaint from a resident
or from myself
i don't get an acknowledgement saying
this email has been received
could i mean we've got a
a good um email system
rit system so can that actually be added
in
so
we don't have residents or ourselves
thinking where has the have you seen it
and then we know it's been actually
received and then we can
as a councillor so we can start tracking
it how long it takes to answer thank you
thanks cancer sure um yeah i believe
that is something that's being looked at
as part of the um yeah customer service
services try to work um
in some departments i do they do sort of
auto generate a reply just to say the
emails being received but i think in
most cases it's kind of assumed that the
emails hit the inbox um and i think it
is just consideration about um
whether it's better for officers to um
spend time sort of writing a response
just to say they've received an email
and that they would get be able to give
a further response within five days or
just to try and
maximize the resource in terms of
replying as quickly as possible so
it's definitely a consideration i don't
have the an answer for you right now but
again we can take that back to the
assistant director for transformation
and customer when i come back you don't
need
officers to spend time writing on them
you can always have just have it there
they press right whatever button and it
automatically as soon as you send
something
you can actually program and say
thank you your email's been received you
do not need anyone to write it out it's
only the first one that we ever get
sorry naomi but that's something yeah
yeah take the point thank you and um as
i said i think some departments do have
auto generated kind of responses already
but that's not consistent across the
board i think just um purposes members
understand um i think sometimes it's
difficult to give an exact response time
because obviously um just be speaking
from experience with the revenues
benefits team different inquiries can
take different times to answer so it's
sometimes difficult to say that all
right
inquiries would be resolved within like
a five day period some can be answered
relatively quickly because they're
simple and some obviously a lot more
complex so it's difficult to give a sort
of generic um answer that you know is
right for every um sort of situation but
certainly i think that's something that
as i say has been considered
thank you
can we pass the um
microphone please counselor
uh
that's all
just a question actually on a different
topic um
on page 618 in appendix 4
reference is made having a single asset
register
so presumably at this time do we just
have a spreadsheet of
different assets
or do we have a system like rbs realtors
or something like that
um through the chair yeah thank you
cancer mills um
so
um the quick answer is yeah yes we do
have a spreadsheet that sort of has a
single um list of kind of land registry
numbers which is a kind of our single
source of asset um in information as a
reference point but different teams do
have their own local records as well for
that they use for their own individual
purposes so for example finance have a
need for different information than the
assets team doing again from legal so
the
intention is that in the um slightly
longer term we could bring all that
information together into um for example
a digital system where all that
information would be held but there is a
single source um kind of spreadsheet at
the moment but it would be nice to bring
all of that information together a bit
more coherently because the a proper
asset system has absolutely everything
from
chairs up to
building sites and um
that's the only reason i mentioned it as
a different council we're looking at
that system and that rbs system and it
was actually relatively inexpensive what
it is
and it gives a single asset register and
i didn't know if we had anything like
that because it saves the risk of
something that's insurable that could be
valuable that we don't know about
and then it goes missing
and we've got a lot of stuff moving
around at the moment because
we're in flux as it were with assets
yeah um that that was just my question
so anyway thanks i think you can answer
that okay
thank you um just to add i believe there
is going to be a
business case coming back to the
executive in terms of some investment in
a sort of asset system as you say at
future points
right
um do we have regular audits or how
often do we have audits of our assets
that they agree with you know physically
agree with what the records show how
does that work
okay
um
so i mean i suppose there's different
levels of control the first kind of
level of control is with the asset team
themselves and obviously they have got
their own asset records and they do sort
of inspections and obviously it's on a
risk basis so um some assets will be
inspected more frequently than others
but they have their own local records
and then i suppose the second level of
control from internal audit perspective
is that they then go in and actually um
look at the control system in place and
that's obviously where this kind of
recommendation has arisen from in terms
of having you know the checks and
balances around all of that as well so
yeah that's basically how the system
works at the moment right okay thank you
did you want to sleep counsellor hi
sorry because i moved my um
i had moved as well
um
it was
the first one was a comment on the the
very many
revised
implementation dates from page six point
one seven onwards
um i've no doubt they're
covered but probably a reason for that
to some extent in the pandemic
the
there's a couple ones i think
apparently on page 6.18 insurance
arrangements
it's apparently got a report is now
autumn 2021 i think this is in a couple
of
months maybe
but you've got the revised end date 31st
of march 2021
um
should that be november october
i can't see it should be march if we're
revising the end dates
um
do you want me to answer that one
i believe that should be 22 on 21 so i
think that's just a typo
so it's going to take six months to
implement four months
um yeah so i think that's um
sorry i'm just looking at the um actual
wedding of the recommendation
um so the insurance arrangement that
links back to the sort of previous
question we had about the kind of asset
register um
yeah yeah so as i said um there's
actually solutions being investigated at
the moment um but the work around that
and investigating the digital kind of um
solutions available will take um a bit
of times which is why the 31st of march
2022
yes that's correct
will that be revised
or assume so um and the next one was
just going back to the earlier
questions about complaints handling will
you be folding to all members the new
um procedures which are promised for the
end of october
and will that be arranged so we can
understand as members how the complete
procedure
yes i believe that will be a document
that will be shared with all members
once it's ready but as i say because i'm
not lead or not i don't know this exact
kind of date when that will be done but
obviously if there's a recommendation
date then um we would seek to you know
meet that deadline
i think it was more the
making sure we as members know what the
new processes and procedures are yeah as
i say um all members that will be shared
with you
that was it thank you
counselor sure
thank you
these agreed implement implement
mentioned dates are these actually
feasible or are we going to have them
put back again
um
okay yeah thanks counselor um
i mean it's very difficult for me to say
obviously with 100 confidence but i
think obviously it's down to the
individual
sort of
owners of these recommendations i think
um obviously each
owner has the best um kind of intentions
when they agree recommendation date and
sometimes for reasons either outside of
their control or um you know limited
resources that they're not always met
but um obviously jim and the team do
follow up on those actively and if there
is a um
a deadline that's not met he does seek
to understand why and obviously give a
clear
update in terms of the audit report um
it is something we always discuss
internally as well um at leadership team
meetings so it's not something that's um
you know taken lightly um but obviously
yes occasionally there are um
reasons why the the original date can't
be met but um i'm not saying that's um
acceptable but that's just a reality i
suppose and if that happens like we've
got someone six point two one yeah the
date thirtieth of the 9th 21
all the audit committee be told on a
separate
uh
document that we can't have these these
will not be me i'm just saying if they
can't be met will we be told separately
or do we have to wait
to the next audit meeting to be told
sorry we've missed them
um
so i think we usually assume that the
date will be met unless we've got read
good reason to believe it won't be
and then obviously this is reported
regularly to audit committee throughout
the year so at the next um available
date um yeah the next available report
that would be reported that the dates
either been met or not on the reason why
so we don't want to keep having a chair
we don't want to keep having surprises
like this and i find it very frustrating
sitting on
two audit committees that i do on two
councils that um it seems acceptable
that oh we're putting the dates back um
we don't really get
the answers on our um external auditors
then have to back along with it do you
mean so i'm just very concerned thank
you
yeah because there's quite a few that um
are due on the 30th of uh this month
um
i think there is several oh sorry check
i think there's several recommendations
that relate to the constitution review
um so that that's one piece of work that
is um you know needs to be completed and
obviously there's a lot of kind of um
different factors involved in that piece
of work so i think that that does relate
to a number of the recommendations that
haven't been met within the time scale
in this report
um as i say i don't think we see it as
acceptable but sometimes that yeah there
is good reason why something has to be
delayed um
but obviously it is within the gift of
audit committee if there's a particular
area that you're interested in or would
you like to ask um you know the relevant
assistant director that we could ask
them to come to the committee and sort
of give an update um obviously as an
audit function we are sort of reporting
on what others are doing and their their
kind of response to the recommendations
but we can't sort of necessarily be
personally responsible for each of those
recommendations but as i say we do
actively chase those up um with with the
um relevant directors if they're not
being met
thank you
okay
seems to be no further questions
there are three recommendations set out
at paragraph 9.1
that the update on delivering the
2021-22 audit plan be noted
that the conclusions and results from
completed audit engagements in
appendices 2 and 3 be noted
and that the updated status of audit
recommendations in impedance 4 be noted
are these noted members
agenda item 7
arrangements to appoint external
auditors from 2023-24
the assistant director resources
naomi lucas will present this report
thank you chair
um i'll just quickly run through this
sort of report so
um the purpose of this report is to seek
an audit committee's recommendation to
council to opt in to the appointing
persons arrangements made by the public
sector audit appointments which are
called psaa
for the council's external auditor
appointment for the periods 2023 24 to
20 27 28
so this committee has responsibility
under its terms of reference for
managing the budget associated with the
external audit fees
and in practical terms this means that
you should be satisfied that the
external auditor's work
is satisfactory and that the fees
represent value for money
so members may or may not be aware that
at the moment the council is currently
opted into the psa arrangements for the
period 2018-19
for the periods 2022-23
um and under that arrangements we've
been allocated by psaa the auditor e y
who are the auditors who will be
carrying out the audit um both this year
and next year
um however we must formally respond to
the invitation to opt-in to the um
framework agreement by the 11th of march
2020 20-22
sorry
um 2022 um to be ready for the
2023-24 financial year
um
and if we choose not to opt into that
arrangement then we must then report
appoint our own auditor by the 31st of
december 2022.
um
under statute it's actually
required that it's full council that
formally makes that decision so audit
committee is just asked to make the
recommendation into full council
so that can be considered um probably at
the camp um the december meeting
so just quickly run through um the
options that are available to the
council
so under um section three so firstly the
council could choose to
create its own auditor panel um which
must be independent um and consists of a
majority of independent members
um that would mean that the council
would have to carry out its own
procurement process
which would obviously have a time and
sort of finance implication for the
council
but the main reason that we're not
recommending that option is that we
wouldn't benefit from the economies of
scale that obviously the psa psaa which
undertakes um the procurement on behalf
of the vast majority of local councils
um can obviously lever in
and therefore the costs would be likely
to be higher
um another key consideration is that if
we were to try and point our own audit
firm
um that um members of the committee will
be aware that um
there's been quite a few difficulties in
terms of available resource to carry out
local government audits and it does risk
that no audio firms would actually be
interested in
auditing us as a small council because
of the the costs and time involved in
doing so so our best chances of actually
securing an audit
contract for the next few years would be
under the psa arrangements
um the second option is to similarly
create an a an auditor panel but to do
it in conjunction with other local
councils
and to undertake a joint procurement
process
that would
perhaps achieve some economies of scale
but i think most of the points i've made
under the previous
option would still hold under under this
option as well
so the option that we're recommending is
option three which is to continue to opt
into the public sector audit appointment
service
um
as it sets out in the report this is the
best opportunity for us to secure
the audit expertise that we need and to
get the best level of fees
it also gives us the benefit of having
an independent third party to deal with
any contractual issues and help manage
those
and psaa have advocated on behalf of
local councils and
between between us and and the auditors
to make sure that we are receiving value
for money
um so we are required under law to
appoint an auditor um by 31st december
2022 otherwise we will be in breach of
the local audit and accountability
act 2014
so i've set out in
section 3 the resource implications of
that
but just to
inform some of the members who may not
be aware that under the arrangements
with psa they basically agree a scale
fee for each council which gives us some
indication of the cost of the contracts
at the start of the contract term
that doesn't mean that's the final fee
um because there are a number of
variables involved um and and a number
of emerging risks um not just for us but
for all councils
um so changes in local arrangements um
within the council can affect the fee as
can new national risks
for example there's often
new legislation and accounting rules are
introduced which increase the complexity
of the accounts that have to be audited
and the third risk is around um if there
is significant errors in the accounts
and obviously the auditors have to take
additional work the following year
and again that can incur additional fees
so at this time it's not possible to
give um
any kind of certainty over the fee level
that would be on that we would um be
subject to under this arrangement
um but we do obviously have currently
have a budget for audit fees um which is
currently 75 000 pounds and we have been
given some additional one-off funding
this year
in recognition of the fact of the
increasing kind of legislation
requirements
that local government is having to face
and that's just under 19 000 pounds for
this year
so as i said at the start we are
recommending um the audit committee
recommends to council that we continue
to opt in to the psa arrangements um for
the accounting period 20 23 24 to 20 27
28th
and if anyone's got any questions i'll
try and answer them thank you
councillor mrs shaw
thank you chad
um naomi do we know what autism ssi look
at who they've gotten their books please
thank you cancer sure um yeah they have
um a number of auditors on their books
um
at the moment it's
generally the big um big accounting
firms so the the names that you'll be
familiar with such as ey grant thornton
etc one of the aspects that they are
considering under this new kind of
framework is
the opportunity to
extend that to more local and smaller
firms to give them the opportunity um so
that is something they're actively
considering but obviously there is a
kind of um
a certain scale of um that would be
needed to deliver this kind of work and
obviously local government accounts in
of themselves are quite complex
so it wouldn't suit itself to say you
know you know a regular kind of small
audit firm it does your defenders need
to be of a sort of certain size to be
able to deal with this kind of work
counselor carter
so
thank you for being patient being taught
how to use microphone
i have a couple of questions please
through the chair
the present contact details for the
present auditors
do we have those and
should a resident wish to write to the
auditor
who would they send it to and in what
format would it be email or written
through the address or telephone
and if the auditors are to consider best
value
when would they do this audit work
oh thank you the counselor um yes
through this chair um yeah so we do have
the auditors some contact details and we
are in regular contact with them um
throughout the year
i suppose it depends on the nature of
the kind of resident query obviously the
um draft accounts um were open for
inspection um
from the period which are published for
a certain period of time which has now
closed so during that time there is a
notice on the website which is still up
there at the moment which gives the um
kind of details of how the resident can
ask a question about the accounts um i
suppose in terms of other more general
queries i would usually um expect them
to be directed through
um i wouldn't normally expect a resident
to make direct contact with the auditors
so i would advise that they were kind of
channeled through um myself probably in
the first instance and i could advise on
the appropriate
way to take that forward um i think
there was another part of your question
which i've just forgotten sorry yeah it
was um if the auditors are to consider
best value when will they do this
yeah yeah so each year the auditors are
required to consider them value for
money arrangements for the council that
forms part of the overall audit
so they obviously um audit the financial
statements for the council but alongside
that they do quite a significant amount
of work around the value for money
arrangements
and they do give an opinion on that as
part of their um audit work which um
obviously has been delayed against
slightly this year but the auditors are
coming in to do their work in october so
we're hoping to bring back that audit
opinion um hopefully to the november
committee but if not as soon as possible
afterwards
councillor hoy was next i don't mind
actual members going first as i'm a
visiting member
can you hear me just out of curiosity
um which option is brentwood council
working to or considering do you know
um i don't really want to speak on
behalf of other councils because i
believe they're obviously taking their
own their own reports and but i believe
they are recommending this the same
option and and we have obviously been in
contact with the number of the essex
authorities um and believe that um most
if not all of them are similarly opting
into this arrangement so we've got no
reason to believe that there's any kind
of appetite to do a kind of joint
procurement locally for for an
alternative arrangement
thank you
councillor hi thank you
thank you for waiting that's okay um
just a
couple of questions um
one comment
i just know the report
does not contain equality on diversity
implications i thought all our reports
should do so
so a bit disappointed on that one um
i'll move on from there
to the appointment
like councilman mr shaw i'm on the essex
audit committee and it it's
quite obvious that there's a long
running issue around
providing audits on time at the moment i
know we have that problem here as well
what
are there is there a league table of
the auditors
of ones which produce them quicker than
others are they all the same
is there a way that we could reject an
auditor if we felt that they
weren't able to provide us with a timely
audit for instance so our bdo quicker
than ernst young
i don't i just wonder if that
information is available if they
do fail to produce
an audit to the time scale
what
penalties are there
are there no penalties are we able to
reduce the audit fee because of that
they're the
two questions because they seem to be
the
the big issues with all within the
public sector at the moment
yeah through the chair thank you um
councillor hoy yeah so i don't believe
there's an um
league table as
such um for the audit firms
but i would just say that i think the
issues experienced by us and other
councils are um but pretty much
experienced across the board so i think
regardless of the audit firm that's been
appointed under the contract i think
most local authorities are finding
themselves in
a similar situation um i think the
obviously underlying factor for that is
just the lack of available audit
resource um for all audit firms to
recruits to um coupled with as i said
earlier the increasing complexity um
of the accounts um or audit process um
so i don't think that it is um yeah
unique to any individual audit firm
um in terms of whether we've got any
come back if we're not happy with the um
service that's provided um obviously our
first kind of um
point is back to psaa
if we've got particular reason to
believe that the auditors haven't
fulfilled um
to the best of their abilities their
work
and there's a particular local issue
obviously we would make representations
to psaa but as i said if it relates to
just the um
kind of
factors with outside outside of each
audit firm's control such as the and the
general audit the market for auditors i
don't think they would see that as a
kind of legitimate reason for us to um
request a change of auditor although it
is possible in some circumstances that
um
you could obviously have a discussion
with psaa about the auditor that you
have been appointed
but i think in practical terms it
wouldn't really make a lot of difference
for us as i've as i've said
um
yeah so i think that's probably as much
as i can really say on that issue could
i just ask one further question on that
um sorry i didn't come to the last audit
meeting so i might be asking something
that's been raised already and i've
missed
um
and it probably goes back to the
previous item as well
i'm very keen that we should always
set realistic time scales to things
even though there might be a requirement
for for us to produce a
legally to produce
the audit report or have it reported
here by a certain date
i think it's much better that we set a
realistic date even if it's
late
um rather than being told that it's
going to be late and it's going to miss
the meeting is that something we're able
to do or is it something that we
shouldn't really do because it's a legal
requirement
and yeah thanks councillor
um so obviously at the start of the year
we make best endeavors to meet the the
deadlines um
but i think quite early on in the
process this year the auditors were
quite open and honest and said that it
was unlikely that they would be able to
meet the um you know the the statutory
um deadlines as such for this for this
year so um we have been quite um kind of
open with the chair of the audit
committee that those deadlines were
unlikely to be to be met this year
obviously government themselves
recognises the difficulties with this
and they've extended the deadlines for
this year and next year in terms of
moving the original dates back from may
to july and the july 1 to september but
even so yeah we won't have the audited
accounts ready for the september for the
end of september this year so um i think
yeah we have tried to communicate openly
um with members the fact that it is
likely to come to a november committee
i'm still
um
cautiously optimistic that that audit
work will be completed and we can take
at least a draft opinion back to the
next committee meeting um but obviously
as i say there's no um cost down iron
guarantees so i think that's the best we
can really do in the circumstances so if
i
what i've probably meant was is it not
necessarily us but the auditors
to say that they will be producing them
in november rather than september
but i'm sure that helps with planning
even if unofficially you know that yeah
so sorry maybe i wasn't clear either but
yeah they they have also been quite
clear with us um from pretty early on
that that they were unlikely to meet
those deadlines so we have been able to
plan in our time to know that they're
coming in october um so obviously that's
aided us with our internal planning but
also enabled us to and
yeah communicate that out to audit
committee members
yes i did make representation last year
because um
because of the lateness and at that time
they did assure us that we would be one
of the first to be audited but
circumstances overtook things but they
do know that we are pushing for them to
um
to look at ours as early as they can but
uh you know we couldn't
we we couldn't do anything about this
one and we did i'm not saying that i
just i think it's better to be realistic
rather than optimistic well yes but i
mean when we made or when i made
representation they they did assure us
that they would be coming in
as as early as they could but uh say
things just
got put back a little bit
i think that's right isn't it naomi yeah
um yeah um at the very start of the year
they were
there was the possibility they would be
able to do us early because obviously
our council already on on time but i
think um
nationally they've taken the decision to
do the larger more complex
authorities at the start of the process
and also they have still got um
audits that are can be completed from
previous financial years which obviously
take precedent over the the new
financial years audits so um as i say
it's slightly out of our control but um
as far as we're concerned they are
sticking to the october date which they
have advised us now for a few months is
the date they would be coming in
any further questions
members there is one recommendation set
out at paragraph 5.1
that the audit committee recommends to
council that the council opts into the
proposed central arrangements for
appointing external auditors for the
accounting periods
20 23 24
to 20 27 28. can those members in favor
please raise their hands
that boat is unanimous
please lower your hands thank you
so that is carried
and members that concludes tonight's
business
thank you very much for your
uh participation and the meeting is
closed at
8 15.
[Applause]
i